long-long gene watches have 110 world's
fair grand prizes twenty eight gold
medals and more honors for accuracy than
any other timepiece launching the
world's most honored watch is made and
guaranteed by the long gene with no
watch company it's time for the
launching horoscope a television journal
of the important issues of the hour
brought show you every Monday Wednesday
and Friday a presentation of the laun
gene which snore what's company maker of
launching the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world honored lawn gene good evening
this is frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the long
gene promise co Colonel Ansel Talbert
one of the editors of the New York
Herald Tribune and mr. William Bradford
Huie
editor of the american mercury our
distinguished guests for this evening is
mr. Henry Wallace former vice president
of the United States the opinions
expressed are necessarily those of the
speakers mr. Wallace you of course are
one of the most controversial political
figures of our time and I believe one of
the most controversial points that
you've ever advocated was American
spending large-scale American spending
abroad now when did you begin advocating
this program sir sometime in 1941 and in
a rather extensive way of 1942 and you
you were a real pioneer in that field
you were one of the first Americans to
so advocate that spending way I was so
recognized at that time and you were
bitterly and assailed I believe that was
referred to as global oniy
the building of TVA's on the danube and
other side says milk for hottentots and
so forth I'm very proud of the names
that were called at that time because
those names cause the people really to
remember that I stood for what has now
looked on increasingly as a very
enlightened program when I has been
spent 10 years now since you began that
advocacy sir and tonight I'm sure that
our Chronicle audience would like to
know exactly where what you think now
about that program and specifically what
the youth regard is the most critical
ear areas in the world today well today
the most critical areas in my opinion
comprise the [ __ ] world extending
from French Morocco on the west all the
way across to the southern part of the
Philippines and including also the Hindu
world and in addition I would say South
Korea because it seems to me absolutely
vital importance if we wish to gain the
sympathy of the peoples of Asia and the
Near East that we do a little job for
the South Koreans as soon as the war
comes to an end if we don't do that real
job to rehabilitate them we will lose
face even more decisively than we would
lose if we lost the war in Korea well
mr. Wallace do you think the American
people have gotten their money's worth
out of this spending yeah what spending
are you referring to sir the foreign aid
which is an extended rather lavishly in
the past eight or nine years are you
referring particularly the Marshall Plan
yeah in Europe and well I think
undoubtedly there been some waste motion
inland the expenditure of the Marshall
Plan aid but it would seem to me to have
contributed maybe 20 percent to the
increase in production that has taken
place that's a rough figure but it's
brought about a very substantial
increase yeah now about our armaments
program mr. Wallace you've been called a
man of peace
do you think our current
armament program is justified and they
cost which it is imposing on the
American people the situation as it has
developed and I regret that it developed
in this way and I don't think it need to
have developed in this way but with it
having developed in this way we did have
to go ahead with a very substantial
armaments program my contention today is
that we take perhaps one percent of this
oncoming armaments program of perhaps
sixty billion dollars a year and devote
that 1% to a peace budget I think we
ought to have a peace budget going along
with our war budget and the peace budget
gradually growing stronger as the war
budget can be reduced now sir you have
said that the critical areas are the
areas around the Iron Curtain
particularly the displaced
Arabs and what would you have us do now
sir in those critical areas specifically
and for the displaced Arabs
well this commit this report of the
committee that was recently made seem to
me to be singly enlightened first of
course there are the immediate need to
these displaced Arabs but far more
important than that the longtime needs
which have to do with the resettlement
of these Arabs by providing adequate
irrigation in that part of the world
which at one time had the most
significant irrigation systems in the
entire world in the Tigris Euphrates
River Valley's you remember that Abraham
came out of were of the kaldanes I
suppose somewhere in Iraq it was a
marvelously fertile civilized area at
one time and can be made so again and
the displaced Arabs if we will step in
decisively and vigorously to help them
it can do a genuine job and in the
process of doing that also we can make
the position of Israel more tenable now
do you advocate this sir purely from
humanitarian motivations no luckily for
humanitarian all over I have observed
this that purity militarism always has
its economic aspects genuine
humanitarianism pays when a
how can it pay the united states other
than just doing a good turn if we step
in there and help those people to a
higher standard of living can it help us
in our war against communism definitely
it makes all the difference in the world
in our war against communism to show
that we can do for them what communism
cannot do the Communists always promised
land of course actually that after the
land has been given they'll charge a
higher rent and was formally charged by
the landlords we can do a real job in
seeing that these displaced Arabs have
land working in cooperation with the
respective governments seeing that they
have the dams are constructed irrigation
canals dug water made available always
having the local government however
contribute its part as well and most of
these governments do have income because
of oil if we do that for them do you
think that will make them prefer us to
what Russia has to offer if we really
understand them if we develop an
extension system in their terms similar
to the extension system which we learned
how to develop for our farmers in their
terms how about the Far Eastern
situation mr. Wallace can we do anything
in the Far East until we have stabilized
the military situation in the Far East
in the Far East and Korea for exhume we
first have to wind up this Korean War
and I realize that that is a difficult
problem but I think that's off to one
side they wouldn't care to get in on
that I really want to say that after the
war is over that we should start on a
very vigorous peace offensive in Korea
that is buy a piece of fencing doing a
real job for the Korean farmers now mr.
Norman Thomas on this show recently said
that as soon as peace comes we must step
up the government expenditures even
larger expenditures more taxes and we're
now levying now do you share that view
sir do you believe that we should have
more taxes more government
in an equal amount spent to what we are
now spending for military activities I
would want this piece budget to come in
as a part of the reduction of the
military budget but with the total
budget being of all kinds being less and
less now I realize that that may be
difficult as long as the world is in
crisis and I don't think anyone can make
an absolute statement as to just what
percentage of our income can be spent on
taxes and our capitalistic economy
survive I don't think anybody can state
that with any finality it depends on the
crisis and the temper of the people if
the people feel that they're in very
grave danger then the changes can then
the taxes can be borne but I certainly
would hope that we could have a much
smaller proportion of our income going
for taxes and at the present time well
mr. Wallace
you've been we've been discussing what
we might do when peace comes how does a
situation for peace look to you right
now peace in Korea some sort of
settlement with the Communists and
Russian
I don't think anyone can say right now
it doesn't look very hopeful does it
well I I have this feeling that in this
kind of a situation that the situation
is won't hopeful but it looks least
hopefully not mr. Wallace as a final
question sir you've always been a man
New York critics conceded a wished
mankind well and at the end of the year
we'd like to know when our audience
would like to know if you see anything
hopeful the 1952 sir yes I see a great
evil that is hopeful as we come to the
end of this year I believe the people of
the United States are closer to facing
the real facts that force is not the
ultimate arbiter that ideas are the
ultimate arbiter that there is such a
thing as carrying out the ideals of
Jesus that you can go forth into all the
world and preach the gospel the gospel
of what the real democracy means the
gospel to every living creature that
Jesus did come that we might all have
life and have it more abundantly and
that that can be implemented with what
we have and the fact ideal which means
so much to humanity cannot be carried
out with what the Communists have but
with what we have if we really mean it
if we put our technology to work in that
spirit in an understanding way in terms
of these people that are producing only
one twentieth as much as we are
producing who want to enjoy the good
things of life who have a right to the
good things of life and can produce
twice as much within ten years they're
producing today well sir I'm sure that
our audience very much appreciate your
views tonight and thank you for being
with us soon the editorial board for
this edition of the launching Cronus
Cove was Colonel Ansel Talbot and the
mr. William Bradford Huie
our distinguished guest was mr. Henry
Wallace former vice president of the
United States